this is Steph Curry the five-time NBA
all-star who's been called the best
shooter in the league's history and this
is his likeness on the top-selling
basketball sim game NBA 2k uncanny right
I've heard people say that Steph Curry
looks more like his 2k avatar than well
Steph Curry that's because of two K's
next-gen character animation which makes
the Virtua hoops game feel real to see
how it's done I caught up with the
creators at 2k and pixel gun studio but
turn me into an avatar in the game I
learned just how they capture even the
tiniest detail from scoring celebrations
to forehead wrinkles making 2k 19 the
most lifelike version of the game yet
half the job of getting a realistic game
involves performance capture it's the
process in which a player's movements
get translated into their character
animations this happens at the 2k mocap
studio a warehouse in Northern
California on the inside it pretty much
looks like a normal basketball court
except you won't find players working
out in their normal uniforms here
instead they wear these skin tight
velcro suits plastic helmets and finger
gloves all of those covered in tiny
rubber balls called markers which are
coated in reflective tape the markers
reflect infrared light back up to 140
cameras inside the studio providing an
outline of the players body as they
dribble and shoot so it starts with
getting them in the suits getting the
markers the right location their body
building their skeleton exactly and then
capturing those movements down to the
millimeter every bounce ever shot every
flick of the wrist we capture every
piece of it just to get that
authenticity the goal is to translate
each player's signature style all the
techniques habits quarks and little
rituals that define their presence on
the court the AMIA talent cows were
prepared
or hand with a shot list of all the
things we'd like to see them do but
what's probably even more important is
collaborating with them while they're on
site asking them what's important what's
signature moves what they like to see in
the game those moves can include a
player's unique jump shot a go-to pass
fake a crossover even little nervous
habits like nail-biting
when you get down to these types of
player specific animations 2k avatars
aren't all created equal the most elite
athletes get the most individualized
animations 2k cover star Steph Curry
even had his famous dribbling warm-up
scan into the game working at the mocap
studio basically sounds like the least
boring job ever when we worked was step
curry he brought in Ayesha with I mean
she was nine months pregnant at the time
and dropped seven three-pointers in a
row it's probably one of the most
memorable experiences I've had here so
performance captures what grabs the
players unique movements and puts them
in the game
the other half of the equation face and
body scans which specifically nailed
down all the details of the players
appearance from their uniform to their
facial expressions even signature
tattoos and accessories to see this part
of the process in action I went straight
to pics events to do they work with 2k
to collect 360-degree body scans of all
the NBA players and for the purposes of
this story me baby I met up with pixel
gun and neljä my scanning session
actually took place in a parking lot of
all places
that's because pixel gun scanner is
housed inside a self-powered RV which
allows their team to be constantly on
the move these doors contract and so it
comes together so they can travel on the
road what that means is we can kind of
roll up at a site and be ready to shoot
in about 20 minutes this idea to become
the first ever mobile scanning studio
was born out of necessity back in 2012
2k challenge pixel gun to scan the
entire NBA with team scattered across
the u.s. spending less than seven
minutes on each player prior to working
everybody in the league and there's I
think 450 players in the league had to
be painstakingly
by hand when we were first approached by
DK it was clear that we had to go to
them and we also had to make the process
as fast and painless as possible
similar to the mocap studio pixel guns
truck is equipped with a hundred and
forty four cameras which take a hundred
and forty-four pictures in a hundredth
of a second their software then
triangulates those fixtures to make it
3d model the subject capturing up to
16,000 different textures their
technology is so high-def it's almost
unsettled we have the reveal their teeth
so we're actually modeling the exact
shape of their teeth it's cutting this
kind of a bummer I'm gonna be honest
getting necklace variety is the key to
showing how your muscles Bend and
contouring different ranges which means
I had to strike a lot of poses for the
camera it's focused so I've got the ball
of your light this one can step outside
and well pixel gun does have players
perform a core series of poses their
scans also leave a ton of room for
personality which for me was awesome I
really got into my you might get dunked
on that guy you sure I think of three to
win the game
[Music]
we have people do it yell like an angry
yell a lot and we actually have them
audibly yell because it helps them hit
the total of it's in there somewhere
let's see encouraging the players to
express themselves during the scans
helps 2k get an appropriate emotional
range in the game we try to get those
expressions that are the most unique and
the most signature to them that includes
athletes mannerisms on the court like
Steph Curry's have it if chewing his
mouthpiece we've scanned him with the
mouth guard in doing that because we
wanted to just sort of capture the way
that would deform his cheeks and stuff
so we kind of knew we were gonna put
that into the game and we wanted to make
sure we got that moment right a lot of
the NBA players do play NBA 2k they're
always looking at themselves and making
sure that their look is accurate pixel
gun will rescan players to make sure
their avatar Staker and when players get
new tattoos they'll often contact to pay
to get their new egg scanned into the
game but nothing is as important as the
sneakers which of course are a big part
of the culture surrounding basketball 2k
takes its shoes very seriously they
meticulously look at all the players in
the game and make sure that their shoes
are exactly right because in that case
it's not just the players that would be
a better fit more accurate but the fans
like the fans are totally in the shoes
and they will call us out
I was excited to see what shoes that
give me in the game how badass I'd look
as a professional Hooper a few weeks
later I was able to see my digital
doppelganger for the very first time
[Music]
let's see this works all right what am i
wearing I love that tank top can I guess
[Music]
[Laughter]
I've never been that pumped about
anything ever ever yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah the most unbelievable thing about
all this is that I'm wearing a tank top
overall I'm very happy now they start
out
[Music]